بعد اقل من اسبوع من حادث المسيره
الامريكيه روسيا تقول انها رصدت قاذفتين
امريكيتين قرب الحدود
رؤساء لجان في مجلس النواب الامريكي
يطالبنا بالاستماع الى مدعي منهتا بشان
اتهامه
اعتقالان اعتقالات واحتجاجات صاخبه في
باريس بعد تبني البرلمان لقانون اصلاح
التقاعد المثيري للجدل
[موسيقى]
نشره اخباريه جديده من العربيه اهلا بكم
قال الرئيس روسيا ان موسكو تلقت باهتمام
مبادره الصين لحل الازمه في اوكرانيا
وانها ستناقشها وتنظر لها بعين الاحترام
على حد تعبيره وخلال استقباله لنظيره
الصيني في موسكو اشار بوتين الى ان حجم
التبادل التجاري بين روسيا والصين بلغ 185
مليار دولار كما اكد الرئيس الروسي لنظيره
الصيني ان هناك الكثير من الاهداف والمهام
المشتركه لبلديهما
على طاوله الزعيمين الروسي والصيني ملفات
كثيره شراكه وتعاون وغرب يجتمعان عليه
اهميه كبيره للعلاقات الصينيه الروسيه
وهناك منطق تاريخي وراء ذلك لاننا اكبر
دولتين متجاورتين بالاضافه الى اننا شركاء
استراتيجيون
يساهم تفاعلنا على الساحه الدوليه بشكل
عام بالطبع في تعزيز المبادئ الاساسيه
لنظام العالمي وتعدد الاقطاب
اوكرانيا لم ترغب طبعا فصين صاحبه خطه
السلام يقول بوتين ان روسيا تلقت المقترحه
باهتمام
لقد درسنا بعنايه مقترحاتك لحل الازمه
الحاده في اوكرانيا ستتاح لنا الفرصه
لمناقشه هذه المساله وسنناقش بالطبع كل
هذه القضايا
البيت الابيض يراقب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيين انتقد الصين واعتبر ان بكين
توفر غطاء دبلوماسيا لروسيا لمواصله
الجرائم في اوكرانيا
ان زياره الرئيس جي الى روسيا بعد ايام من
اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لمذكره
توقيف بحق الرئيس بوتين تشير الى ان الصين
لا تشعر باي مسؤوليه في محسبه كرملين على
الفضاء التي ارتكبت في اوكرانيا
وبالتزامن مع هذه الزياره اعلنت وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه عن تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه ومعدات بقيمه 350 مليون دولار
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره دفاع روسيه اعتراض
قاذفتين استراتيجيتين
تابعتين للقوات الجويه الامريكيه على
الحدود الروسيه فوق بحر البلطيق واعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الدفاعات الجويه
رصدت القاذفتين تحلقان فوق بحر البلطيق في
اتجاه الحدود الروسيه كما اضافت ان مقاتله
من طراسو 35 حلقت الاعتراض القاذفتين ثم
عادت الى قاعدتها مشدده على ان المقاتله
روسيه امتثلت للانظمه الدوليه المتعلقه
باستخدام المجال الجوي منعا لانتهاك
الحدود الروسيه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ارسل ثلاثه
رؤساء لجان في مجلس النواب خطابا الى
المدعي العام في منهطن الديمقراطي
يطالبون فيه مدعيما هاتا بالادلاء بشهادته
وتقديمي نسخ ومعلومات حول التهم المواجهه
الى الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب والتي
وصفوها بانها اساءه غير مسبوقه لسلطه
الادعاء العام لكن يبدو انه من غير المرجح
ان يستجيب كل من براجوا وزاره العدل لهذا
الطلب نظرا للممارسه طويله الامد المتمثله
في عدم افشاء المدعين لمعلومات حول
القضايا الحساسه
هذا وكان مسؤولون امريكيون قالوا لمجله
بلوتيكو انه سيتم بحث وصول الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الى المحكمه
مع جهاز الخدمه السريه وشرطه نيويورك وان
قرار الاصفاد في ايدي ترامب من صلاحيه
المدعي العام لمن هتلف من جهته قال حاكم
فلوريدا انه لن يتورط في عمليه تسليم
ترامب الى السلطات نيويورك ووفقا لمسؤولين
امريكيين فان اجراءات التخطيط الداخليه
للتعامل مع الرئيس السابق سيكون باعتقاله
اذا لم يستسلم
الامر متروك
وسمعنا الكثير من التقارير لكن المدعي
العام سيتخذ هذا القرار ونحن سنفعل ما
نفعله دائما كما تعلمون نحن نراقب
التعليقات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وتؤدي شرطه نيويورك دورها الطبيعي في
التاكد من عدم وجود اجراءات غير لائقه في
المدينه نحن على ثقه اننا سنكون قادرين
على القيام بذلك
ووسط تصاعد توتر بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين جراء التسريبات حول اعتقال
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يتخوف الساسه الامريكيين من التكرار
سيناريو اقتحام الكابيتول عقب دعوه ترامب
لانصاره بتنظيم احتجاجات حاشده
قد تبدو هذه الاجواء هادئه لكنها اشبه
باجواء ما قبل العاصفه عاصفه رياحها
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
ان سيطر على شاشات التلفزه بدعوه انصاره
لتنظيم احتجاجات حاسده
الاحتجاجات المرتقبه اقلقت السلطات
الامريكيه من تكرار سيناريو اقتحام
الكابيتول الامريكي على يد مناصري ترامب
وامكانيه خروجها عن نطاق السيطره وتحولها
الى عمليات عنف وتخريب وفيما يشبه الهجوم
المضاد ندد رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن ماكارتي بتحقيق المدعي العام بحق
ترامب واصفا الامر بالمسيس رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن ماكارتي
لا يهم اي جانب من المشكله انت الان لا
يهم ما اذا كان هذا هو الرئيس ترامب او
اذا كان ديمقراطيا يجب ان تكون هذه عداله
متساويه في امريكا وان تتوقف عن ملاحقه
الناس لان لديهم خلافات سياسيه
دعوه ترامب للتصعيد في الشارع رافقها
تاييد من كبار المسؤولين ابرزهم السيناتور
الذي حثت رمب على المقاومه واخذ القضيه
الى المحكمه العليا
تصعيد الجمهوريين قابله اخر ديمقراطي
بدعوى ان ما يجري محاولات جديده لخدمه
مصالح ترامب
السيناتور الديمقراطيه الى
هذه حاله اخرى
افاد مرسل العربيه في باريس بان حاله من
الفوضى العارمه تعم شوارع العاصمه وعددا
من المدن الفرنسيه بعد تمرير قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد ففي العاصمه باريس اطلقت
الشرطه الغزل المسيله لدموع كما قامت
بعمليات اعتقال عشوائيه في صفوف المحتجين
على قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد هذا فيما
اضرم محتجون النار في عدد من المناطق كما
دعا سياسيون فرنسيون المواطنين الى نزول
الى الشوارع مطالبين رئيسه الوزراء
بالاستقاله
هذا وكان البرلمان الفرنسيه اعتمد قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد بعد النجاه الحكومه من
تصويتين لحجب الثقه عنها امام مجلس النواب
وتمكنت حكومه ماكرون من النجاه بفارق ضئيل
حيث صوت 278 نائبا لصالح سحب الثقه وهو
اقل بتسعه اصوات عن المطلوب لحجب الثقه عن
الحكومه هذا وانسحب اعضاء البرلمان
الفرنسي من القاعه الرئيسيه للجمعيه
الوطنيه بعدما فشلت قوى المعارضه في حشد
عدد كاف من الاصوات
هذه النشره مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
غضب واسع من تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي والرئاسه الفلسطينيه تعتبرها
محاوله لتزييف التاريخ
اهلا بكم من جديد اغلقت اسهم البنوك
الاوروبيه على ارتفاع بعد ان شهد التراجعا
في بدايه تداوله الامس بسبب تدعيه ازمه
بنك اما سهم كريدي سويس فقد اغلق على
انخفاض بنسبه 56 بالمئه هذا وكانت الحكومه
السويسريه وافقت على استحواذ بنك يوبي اس
على بنك كريدي سويس في صفقه بقيمه بلغت
ثلاثه مليارات دولار
ازمه ثقه وفضائح عده للسنوات تضمنت تهما
بغسيل اموال وكذلك احتيال ضريبي جميعها
عوامل ساهمت بنهايه تاريخ بنك السويس الذي
يعود لاكثر من 160 عاما
يواجه بانكوك الذي تم تاسيسه منذ اكثر من
160 عاما سلسله من الفضائح خلال السنوات
الماضيه كلفته مليارات الدولارات وتعرض
ثاني اكبر بنك في سويسرا لغرامات وعقوبات
تتعلق بتهم عده ابرزها تهم غسل الاموال
والاحتيال الضاربي ففي فبراير من عام 2020
تعرضت لفضيحه تجسس في البنك ادت الى راحيل
رئيسه التنفيذي تيجان تيام استهدفت كبار
المديرين السابقين ومنظمات وفي مارس 2020
الدانهيار صندوق الاستثمارات الامريكيجوس
كابيتال الى تكبدسويس خسائر قدرها 5
مليارات و500 مليون دولار بسبب انكشافه
على الصندوق وفي الشهر نفسه اضطر البنك
السويسري الى تجميد 10 مليارات دولار من
صناديق تمويل سلاسل الامداد المرتبطه
بجرينسيل
خدمات الماليه البريطانيه المفلسه التي
سوقها البنك لعملائه على انها منتجات
منخفضه الخطوره وفي عام 2021
استقال انطونيو هورتا اوسوريو من منصب
رئيس مجلس الاداره بعد اقل من تسعه اشهر
من انضمامه
بسبب انتهاكه قواعد الحجر الصحي الخاصه
بكورونا وفي اكتوبر عام 2022 اعلنت عن خطه
شامله لاعاده التركيز على الخدمات البنكيه
للاثرياء بجانب جمع راس مال بقيمه 4
مليارات فرنك سويسري وتخفيض عدد الموظفين
بواقع تسعه الاف بحلول نهايه عام 2025
وفصل خدماته البنكيه الاستثماريه في وحده
جديده باسم سيسي اسفرس بوستون وخلال الشهر
الحالي اشار التقرير السنوي لخدي سويس الى
اوجه ضعف جوهريه في الض وابط الداخليه
لاعداد التقارير الماليه سعى حمدان
العربيه
افاد مصدر في وزاره الخارجيه الاردنيه
باستدعاء السفير الاسرائيلي في عمان وذلك
في اعقب تصريحات الوزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي وصفتها عمان بالعنصريه
والتحريضيه ومتطرفه وكذلك واستخدامه
لخريطه لاسرائيل تضم مناطق اردنيه
بدوره اعتبر الاتحاد الاوروبي تصريحات
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي بشان الفلسطينيين
خطيره وغير محترمه كما دعى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه للتنصل منها هذا في مقاله
رئاسه الفلسطينيه ان التصريحات العنصريه
لوزير الماليه الاسرائيلي والتي انكر فيها
وجود الشعب الفلسطيني هي محاوله لتزييف
التاريخ وتسويره
اسبوعان تقريبا يفصلان بين تصريحين
اسرائيليين فجرى غضبا داخليا وادانات
خارجيه واسعه بعد دعوه وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
طلب فيها بمحو بلده حوار الفلسطينيه يعني
اعتقد ان قريه حواره بحاجه الى محو اعتقد
ان على دوله اسرائيل ان تفعل ذلك
بعد سموتر بتصريحات استفزت داخل الفلسطيني
قال فيها ان الشعب الفلسطيني اختراع لم
يتجاوز عمره 100 سنه لا يوجد فلسطينيون
لانه لا يوجد شعب فلسطيني السلطه
الفلسطينيه صارت للتنديد بتصريحات الوزير
الاسرائيلي المتتاليه الرئاسه وصفتها
بتزييف للتاريخ ودليل على عصوريه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي تنكرها فيما رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد اشتيه استنكر
تصريحات اسمنتج ووصفها بالعنصريه
والتحريضيه دليل قاطع على الفكر الصهيوني
لعنصر المتطرف الذي يحكم اطراف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه
ورغم التمديدات الداخليه والخارجيه بتصعيد
غير المبرر لتصريحات العدائيه يقف رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
موقفا صامتا ولا يضع حد له
امر قد تبرره خبايا المشهد السياسي في
اسرائيل
فنتنياهو كون حكومته من ائتلاف حرج يضم
فيه احزاب اقصى اليمين يخشى ان يؤدي
اصطدامهم مع انهيار ائتلافه وبالتالي
حكومته بالكامل هنا قد تكون اسباب استمرار
تجاوزات رئيس الماليه الاسرائيلي واضحه
فوز علم الصهيونيه الدينيه
ونتنياهو لا يرغب في خساره تاييد حزب
النافذ فمحاوله معارضته قد تكلفه خساره
السلطه
اعلن برنامج الغذاء العالمي عن انخفاض
التمويل من المانحين يمكن ان تدفع مناطق
من افغانستان الى المجاعه هذا العام وحسب
البرنامج الامي فانما يصل الى تسعه ملايين
من المواطنين الافغان قد يصبح بدون
مساعدات غذائيه بعد ان تم خفض حصص الاعشاء
يذكر انه بعد سيطره طالبان افغانستان قامت
عدد من الحكومات الاجنبيه بقطع برامج
التمويل ما ادى الى تفاقم الوضع الانساني
في البلاد
قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان ان عشرات القضايا مرفوعه ضده لاسباب
سياسيه واضاف خان في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه ان الهدف من هذه القضايا هو
ابعاده عن الانتخابات
هناك نحو مئات قضيه مرفوعه ضدي وهذه
القضايا تشمل مزاعم التحريض والارهاب وحتى
قضايا قتل حيث اتهموني بقتل شخص كل هذه
القضايا وراءها دوافع سياسيه لابعاد عن
الانتخابات فالمشكله هي ان المعارضه تعرف
تماما انها لا تستطيع الفوز بالانتخابات
ومن بين الانتخابات الفرعيه البالغ عددها
37 مقعدا فزنا ب 30 منها فهم قلقون من ان
مشاركتنا في انتخابات الثلاثين من ابريل
ستلحق الهزيمه بهم وهم يخشون من ذلك وهم
يحاولون ابعاد عن سباق الانتخابات من خلال
اقامه كل هذه الدعاء وضدي
كما قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان الحكومه لم توفر له الحمايه
خلال جلسات محاكمته واضاف في مقابلتهم مع
العربيه ان حياته مهدده وانه رغم ذلك حضر
كل الجلسات باستثناء واحده بسبب اصابته
خلال محاوله اغتياله الاخيره
سبق ان حضرت جلسات المحاكمه كلها والمره
الوحيده التي تخلفت فيها عن الحضور كانت
بعد اصابته اثناء المحاوله التي تعرضت
فيها للاغتيال والتي حالت دون الذهاب الى
المحكمه لمده اربعه اشهر لكنني كنت مقعدا
في البيت بسبب اصابه في قدمه قبلها كنت
اذهب الى كل جلسات المحاكمه مع عدا واحده
وسبب ذلك هو ان مبنى المحكمه غير امن فهم
لم يوفروا لي الحمايه وحياتي كانت مهدده
على الرغم من ان الحكومه اعلنت ان حياتي
مهدده الا انها لم توفر للحمايه وفي تلك
المحكمه حصلت قبل ذلك عمليتين ارهابيتين
نجمتا عن مقتل قضاه ومحامين وعندما نق لت
المحاكمه الى المجمع القضائي
ذهبت الى هناك يوم السبت ومثلت امام هيئه
المحكمه
هذا وتتابعون المقابله كامله والتي اجرتها
الزميل مع رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان غدا الاربعاء في تمام الساعه 16
بتوقيت جرينتش السابعه بتوقيت الرياض
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه قال وزير التجاره
السعوديه الدكتور ماجد القصبي ان المملكه
وشعبها استقبلوا بكل ترحيب ما وصلت اليه
العلاقه مع ايران مضيفا ان ايران بلد جار
وان السعوديه تدفع بكل الجهود الراميه
للتنميه والاستقرار والسلام المملكه وشعب
المملكه والمنطقه استقبلت بكل ترحيب ما
وصلت اليه فايران ايضا جار
وندعو الله ان ان يديم هذا الاستقرار
ونركز على التنميه وان ينفع بكل الجهود
التي تبذل السلام والاستقرار
هكذا وزير الخارجيه تركي مولود شاويش
اوغلو ان جهود التقارب مع سوريا متواصله
حيث عقد الجانبان سلسله من الاجتماعات على
الصعيدين الزمني والعسكري وقال الوزير
التركي في رده على سؤال العربيه ان الجهود
الجاريه تهدف الى وضع حد للفوض السائده
منذ 11 عاما في سوريا مضيفا ان تركيا
ملتزمه باحترام مبدئي ووحدتي الاراضي
السوريه
لا نتحدث عن تطبيع العلاقات مع سوريا
وانما عن الحوار بين الجانبين لان
المباحثات تجري مع ممثلي الاداره السوريه
نبذل ما في وسعنا ونهدف الى وقف الفوضى
السائد منذ 11 عاما في سوريا عدم
الاستقرار وانعدام النظام الاعمال
العدائيه والحربيه نسعى الى وضع حد لهذه
الفوضى جهود عده بذلت في هذا الاتجاه
مبادره عده اطلقت وتم انشاء مجموعه اتصال
دوليه حول سوريا وهناك ايضا منصه اسيتان
التي تضم تركيا وسوريا وايران
اكدت الامم المتحده على ان نصف مليون سوري
من دون ماوى وان 90% من السوريين يعيشون
تحت خط الفقر خاصه بعد ان دمر الزلزال 650
وحده سكنيه في سوريا كما اوضحت الامم
المتحده ان حاجات التاهيل العاجله في
سوريا تتراوح بين 7.9
مليار دولار حسب البنك الدولي واكده ان
السوريون مهددون بان يكونوا رهينه دائره
الفقر والعنف والكوارث الصحيه التي تشهدها
البلاد
استخدم الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الفيتو
الرئاسي للمره الاولى في عهده ضد اقتراح
قانون قدمه الجمهوريون للحد من قدره
الصناديق التقاعديه على القيام باستثمارات
تراعي المعايير البيئيه والاجتماعيه
والحكم الرشيد وجاء في تغريده اطلقها
بايدن ان التشريع من شانه ان يعرض الخطر
لمضخرات التقاعد وذلك بجعل النظر في عوامل
الخطر غير قانونيه وهو ما يعارضه جناح
اليمين المتطرف في الحزب الجمهوريه اذ
يعتبر جمهوريون ان ما يسمى بالاستثمارات
المسؤوله امر ينطوي على تدخل سياسيه
من جهه اخرى اصدر الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قانونا يرفع سريعا معلومات
استخباراتيه حول وجود روابط محتمله بين
منشا فيروس كورونا ومختبر في مدينه وهران
الصينيه كما شدد بايدن في بيانه على ضروره
التوصل الى منشا كورونا بما في ذلك روابط
محتمله مع معهد يوهان لعلم الفيروسات اضاف
بايدن ان ادارته سترفع السريه وستنشر اكبر
قدر ممكن من المعلومات حول هذا الامر
نقلت شبكه سي ام بي سي الامريكيه عن رساله
داخليه في شركه امازون انها ابلغت
الموظفين بعمليه تسريح اضافيه لتسعه الاف
موظف واعلنت امازون في يناير الماضي عن
تسريح اكثر من 18000 موظف في عده اقسام
منها المتاجر والموارد البشريه ليبلغ بذلك
اجمالي من سيتم تسريحهم لسبعه وعشرين الف
موظف
احتفلت قناه العربيه في الرياض بمرور 20
عاما على تاسيسها والذي كان في مارس من
عام 2003 الحفله شهد حضورا لوزراء
ومسؤولين رفيع المستوى من المنطقه كما
استذكر رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ
وكذلك الطريق الصعبه الذي سلكته للوصول
الى ما هي عليه اليوم في حين استعرض
الرئيس التنفيذي لمجموعه ام بي سي سامبا
النجاحات التي راكمتها القناع طوال عقدين
فيما تحدث المدير العام لقناتي العربيه
والحدث عن نهج الاعتدال الذي ما زالت
القناه تعتبره منهجا لطرحها الحفل شهد
ايضا حضورا لابرز الاعلاميين وصناع الراي
العام في العالم العربي
نبقى ايضا في الرياض من حيث انطلقت اذاعه
العربيه اف ام الاذاعه تقدم تغطيه للاخبار
السياسيه وكذلك الاقتصاديه والرياضيه على
مدار الساعه اضافه الى رصد ومواكبه
الاخبار العاجله محليا وعالميا كما انها
تضم الاذاعه شبكه من المراسلين في كافه
انحاء العالم
وراها كل خبر قصه تروى تدقيق ورصد بالصوره
شاشه يمتد عمرها لاكثر من عشرين عاما ان
تعرف اكثر مهمه العربيه من عام لاخر الان
جاء دور الصوت والكلمه من العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض ولدت اذاعه العربيه
العربيه اف ام تضعك في الصوره لتعرف اكثر
ومن قلب استوديوهات الاخبار بالرياض بضاعه
العربيه تكمل الصوره خبرا لكل المستمعين
فصلكم حيثما كنتم اسرع من اي وقت اتمنى ان
يصلكم الخبر فور حدوثه واينما كنتم بالصوت
والكلمه سنقدم لك كل ما يهمك ان تعرفه عبر
صباح العربيه
لطالما كانت الفكره وتفرد المحتوى هما حجر
الزاويه منذ نشاه العربيه تواصل الخزاعه
المشوار بخطه ثابته في بث يمتد عبر الاثير
والوسائط المتعدده الى مستمعيها في العالم
اجمع
عصام عبد السلام اذاعه العربيه اف ام
الى عناوين هذه النشره
بعد اقل من اسبوع من حادث مسيره الامريكيه
روسيا تقول انها رصدت قاذفتين امريكيتين
قرب الحدود
رؤساء لجان في مجلس يطالبون بالاستماع الى
مدعي منه هاتم بشان اتهامه لترامب
اعتقالات واحتجاجات صاخبه في باريس بعد
تبني البرلمان لقانون اصلاح التقاعد
المثيري للجدل
نلتقي بعد قليل في امان الله
[موسيقى]